so just a few updates and a few
complaints okay I don't really have
something new to talk about today but I
just want to talk about sort of the
general status of things in general and
let's start with something that you have
probably heard other channels inform you
of if you are on YouTube much at all but
just in case
YouTube has started being very squirrely
with subscriptions and actually having
things that you are subscribed to show
up in your subscription feed one would
think that if you subscribed to a
channel it's because you want to see
their stuff in your subscription feed
YouTube would beg to differ apparently
it is becoming increasingly common for
any YouTube channel that is not of
significant size and by significant size
I mean like under a million subscribers
to start to not show up in the in some
people's subscription feeds anymore this
includes if you hit that stupid friggin
bell so apparently at an increasing rate
no matter what whether you're subscribed
rang the bell you may not get
notifications that new stuff is out
there so first of all screw you YouTube
like I I know I'm biting the hand that
feeds me it's the it's my platform of
choice I do understand that but at the
same time the way what YouTube is seems
to very clearly be doing at this point
is that YouTube spend its first oh I
don't know six to ten years or so
building or building a space where
people could gain their audiences um
where people could get big in theory now
that it's been going for a while
YouTube seems to have decided it doesn't
want more creators it wants fewer
creators with more subscribers so they
keep making changes that are detrimental
to like set basically anyone under a
million and because I there were
channels I subscribe to with hundreds of
thousands of subscribers where this is a
rampant problem for them their
subscribers are not finding their stuff
so YouTube is at this point catering to
its biggest channels and not just
ignoring actively damaging everybody
else so the first thing that I'm going
to recommend because if you go to my
channel page you'll find all the new
videos so you know if you're willing to
do that that'll work
I find that to be a hassle like I look
at how many channels I'm subscribed to I
don't want have to click on one of those
yeah I have to remember to go to their
main channel page to be able to see if
there's anything new that's what the
subscription feed is supposed to be
doing for me so assuming that you're not
doing that then there are basically
three other avenues where YouTube
doesn't have control over whether what
you see there once my Twitter feed at
Council of geeks one is the council of
geeks Facebook page and the other is of
course patreon all three of those get
updates and note and notified every
single time a new video goes up which
brings me to my second thing moving away
from YouTube jerkish miss and again - I
was gonna say more positive maybe it's
just insane I am on a rather lengthy
streak at this point of doing a video a
day I don't know how that happened I
didn't mean for that to happen I don't
know how long that's gonna continue but
first of all there's your clue if you're
missing videos if you're not if you're
looking at your subscription feeding
you're not seeing a new thing from me
every day you're missing stuff
so I and I'll try and be done talking
about that but yeah I have somehow
stumbled into a video a day I think it's
a combination of two things I've tried
to get much better at anything that I
don't need a fast turnaround on trying
to do it in advance so you know for
existing things I need a fast turnaround
on is any any news or new trailer or
review of a newly released episode of
something those I have to turn around
quickly anything else like classic who
reviews most lists that I do you know
sorry if I do anything that's a bit more
retro a sort of a retrospective review
some of the editorial stuff I do a lot
of that I can and do record in advance
what that means is is that I have a
bunch of sudden it's sort of the way I
plan it is I tend to plan four to five
videos a week pretty much all
pre-recorded stuff but then it only
takes two or three either new ideas to
come into my head or new stories to
break your trailers to drop and suddenly
I've got a video a day and sometimes to
the point that I've even had to take
stuff that I was planning to release
that week and bump it to later to make
room for the stuff I need to do quick
turnaround on so this is just kind of
happened and it's crazy and I'm kind of
riding high on it a little bit again if
I start to feel burnout from it
I'll take a step back I'm doing okay so
far we'll see if that if that holds up
there is a possibility of burnout if for
no other reason then you know this isn't
my living I've got a full-time job and
the kid and I perform in burlesque shows
and I'm trying to get a book published
like I
the amount of stuff that I do is kind of
crazy but yeah video a day that's not
that's kind of cool like I think at this
point I might have I should have checked
the numbers on this I might have
actually exceeded for 2018 I I think
I've put out more videos than I did in
the entirety of 2017 like I think in a
little over seven months I beat what I
did in twelve holy cow so as far as
other things go and future plans go the
podcast feed that's gonna start having
content again soon I don't have a launch
date yet but this is gonna be within the
next I'd say two weeks this will launch
and I am going to be doing episode by
episode reviews of Cowboy Bebop and that
was the series selected by my supporters
on patreon plug it again
I think that's three so far I keep it up
maybe I'll get a bingo and because I had
a number of options I thought well you
know there's a number of shows that I
really like and I would love to revisit
and that I have the whole runs of but I
can't justify you know especially when
I'm filling up a week already I can't
justify dropping a you know a day on
these old shows that nobody's watching
anymore and of the options I gave my my
patrons they opted for Cowboy Bebop so
what's gonna happen is on the podcast
feed the council of geeks podcast feed
which is not which I haven't been
linking down in the description because
I haven't been updating it I've only
been listening it'll it
I've only been linking to the podcasts
that I do with my partner Liz so I gotta
remember to add
so that'll those will start going up and
and I'll be doing episode by episode
reviews once a week on Cowboy Bebop
until I'm done man I'll include the
movie in there I'm gonna I need to look
up when it's Lots in chronologically cuz
I figure that's what I'll drop it in and
then once that's done I will probably do
as an animation junkie special a
retrospective on the whole thing I think
that's about it that I that I'm gonna do
for updates I've got a ton of other
stuff planned for you know for this
month feel like I've I have a docket
laid out I've got plans way into next
year like not like video a day plans but
like I've got stuff that I've had - I've
had I've got stuff locked down as far as
June of 2019 you know just in the
interest of stuff that I want to talk
about but not overloading similar kind
of content that's you know that's pacing
things out by doing things like trying
to not do more than one Doctor Who list
in a month that's you know only doing
one Big Finish or one classic whoo-hoo
review a month that's accounting for the
fact that I'll be having actually
episodes of of that to review that's
sort of spacing out trying not to do
more than one episode of why it's
awesome a month no more than one episode
of good movie bad endings for a month
just spacing out the various sub series
that I've ended up with has put me way
far into the future so assuming you
don't burn out if this keeps building
I'm gonna be busy for a long time and
that's kind of exciting and I want to
thank you if you're still watching at
this point you're awesome because
whether you are a patron or not I would
appreciate it but whether you're a
patron or not I appreciate the support
that I get from my subscribers and the
people who watch my videos because even
as the channel has grown
- literally beyond what I was capable of
doing I honestly didn't think I was ever
going to break 10,000 subscribers on
YouTube and I'm more than doubled it and
so now being at a point truly beyond
what I ever thought was possible for me
on here I appreciate every last one yeah
you guys are awesome so if you want to
ensure that you get the the updates
Facebook Twitter patreon I would
recommend you know what I'll do one last
thing mentioning on the page run I'm I'm
at a point now with number of
subscribers if 10% of my subscribers
supported me at $2 a month on patreon I
could afford to make this my full-time
job that's an unreasonable expectation I
know that like it's real you don't get
that kind of percentage you know
translating but it's it's becoming more
feasible it's not as ridiculous a notion
as it once seemed which is crazy but
awesome so thank you so folks that'll
wrap up this one I don't plan to do
these sort of kind of just general
updates all that much but enough sort of
stuff was either coming down the pipe or
was going on and you know YouTube BS
that I just kind of wanted to just
addressed it specifically one video
instead of having to tack these things
on at the front end or or the back end
of videos on other topics oh there we go
hope you don't mind me up one day with
this sort of general update but hope you
found that helpful thank you for
watching whatever your thoughts are on
what's going on my things that my plans
that I've described you or anything else
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's all the
stuff to do you know what it is links in
the description I've been talking about
it the whole time so you don't need me
to go through it remember
folks you are the council I only run the
meetings so until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]